always argue your bills because a lot of
them are mistakes like I didn't write
the code that would get your test
covered as a doctor because I have no
idea so someone in administration can
change the code and get it covered
that's number one number two and let's
say you're paying out of pocket you have
no insurance and you go to the emergency
room a hospital charges a hundred
dollars for an emergency appendix
removal they have to charge you as a
cash user the same amount by law in
order to charge it to the health
insurance company but they know why
they're charging them a hundred because
they'll only pay them 60. that's the
deal that they have with the health
insurance so when you get the bill for a
hundred and you argue they'll right away
lower it to 60. if you claim financial
hardship
wow I think you just saved a lot of
people